[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
and were you able to identify who this
person was yes and who was that for
ahmad witnesses who responded to the
scene take the stand in the death of
ahmad arbory trial and an annual concert
turns deadly they set up the barricade
so it's basically a death trap what led
to eight deaths many injuries and
lawsuits at last weekend's astroworld
festival plus
new court filings in the case of the
so-called doomsday duo why chad dabel's
defense team say he deserves a special
hearing and later hear from the only man
who survived being shot by kyle
rittenhouse any time you bring a firearm
into that equation
the stakes are much higher we'll take
you inside the courtroom for more on the
contentious case law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i am imran ansari in for brian buckmeyer
who is in georgia covering the death of
ahmad arby trial alongside me here in
new york is co-host terry austin
after weeks of jury selection monday
marks day two for the georgia men on
trial in the death of ahmad arbury
gregory and travis mcmichael and william
roddy bryan all face charges of malice
murder felony murder and aggravated
assault for the shooting death of the 25
year old jogger prosecutors say that the
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael tailed arbory in their pickup
truck as he ran near his home in georgia
back in february of 2020.
travis mcmichael shot and killed arbury
and is claiming self-defense
brian followed along in his own vehicle
recording on his phone
the trial is being held in a courthouse
in glenn county georgia
and that is where our very own brian
buckmeyer joins us now live brian you've
been following this case very closely
what are some of the takeaways from the
start of this week
yes imran so two officers on the day of
ahmad aubry's death testified on the
second day of trial officer ramos gave
the jury the lay of the land as she saw
through crime scene investigation photos
pictures of blood-stained driveways the
12-gauge shotgun and ahmad arbori's body
laying on the ground on
cross-examination jason sheffield
travis's lawyer got out at the area
where aubrey ran wasn't searched for
anything that he may have thrown during
the chase he also highlighted that many
of the homes in the area did not have
fences seeming to suggest that aubrey
may have been able to run and escape in
a different direction former glenn
county officer ricky minju took the
stand describing the pool of blood
surrounding aubrey and the death rattle
that he heard from aubry minshew
detailed his interview with william
roddy bryan immediately after the
shooting brian referred to aubry as a
quote joker but said he never heard the
25 year old make any threats
now did brian have a cell phone on him
during this time when he's chasing your
mom okay did he ever tell you that he
called 9-1-1 or anything no he did not
tell me he never mentioned it okay
did brian ever see a mod with any kind
of weapon
uh he never told me he saw the weapon
okay you uh specifically asked him about
a weapon and whether he saw one
uh i don't recall
okay but brian never told you he saw it
that's correct he never told me it's all
with him okay
did brian ever say ahmad made any verbal
threats towards him during this time
when he was being chased no ma'am he
said he didn't hear him ever say
anything
okay so brian do you get the feeling
that defense attorney kevin goff is now
doubting the number of times brian cut
off or even cornered arbor
it was interesting imran during a
cross-examination kevin goff did bring
that up in the transcripts through the
officer but on redirect the prosecution
brought up that there was different uses
of the words that cut off blocked off
angled or cornered were all used to
describe what kevin uh sorry what
william bryant did or at least said he
did to a mod aubry to the officer
yeah and brian we've seen family members
in the courtroom both related to victim
ahmad arbory and the defendants travis
and gregory mcmichael what can you tell
us about their presence in the courtroom
yeah so in the court imran we have lee
mcmichael that is the mother of
travis and michael and therefore the
wife of gregory mcmichael she's often
sitting in the courtroom looking
straight ahead at times looking down
during some of the difficult testimony
and of course you have wanda cooper
jones the mother of ahmad aubry and
marcus aubry senior the father in court
they're often in court sometimes even
whispering in an audible uh noise to be
able to say for example that the defense
attorney for michael william bryan sorry
is delaying with some of their emotions
in lemonade and also gasping at some of
the more and difficult viewings of ahmad
aubry's body juana cooper jones often
staying for those difficult viewings and
the father electing to step out because
as he said to us outside it's hard for
him to see his son die in this way brian
thank you for that excellent reporting
down there in georgia and now on to an
update out of florida where the penalty
phase for convicted murderer markeith
lloyd is pushed back to next month this
delay comes as a judge rules use of
force by police officers can now be used
in lloyd's sentencing the judge ruled
that jurors will be able to hear about
the force used during lloyd's arrest
including what led to the loss of his
eye in 2017 lloyd was on the run after
he shot and killed pregnant
ex-girlfriend jodae dixon he also shot
and killed lieutenant debra clayton who
was attempting to apprehend him after
that lloyd lost his eye as a result of
officers use of force loyd is already
serving a life sentence for dixon's
murder he avoided the death penalty in
that case but prosecutors are now
seeking the death penalty in the case of
lieutenant clayton's murder loyd was
scheduled to be sentenced over the
weekend the penalty phase has been
pushed back to december 6th
and still ahead on law on crime daily
half of the doomsday duo could be headed
back to court in idaho as chad davao's
attorney requests an evidentiary hearing
but first what was meant to be a fun
music festival turns deadly what went
wrong at the astroworld festival and
what legal action could soon follow all
that coming up after the break
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galvado gavel coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back over the weekend eight
people were killed and others injured
during the astro world concert in
houston texas
at least two lawsuits have been filed
are more likely to come law and crime's
anget levy is here with the details
imran travis scott and drake were the
big draws last friday night at this
concert and people who attended said the
crowd was pushing toward the straight
stage which led to some people being
crushed
and injured
this is what it looked like outside of
houston's nrg park the morning after
eight people were killed at the
astroworld concert travis scott
headlined the event drake also performed
by the time travis came out on stage
everyone was squished there wasn't a
centimeter between people no one could
breathe no one was having fun the entire
show billy nasser was on the floor at
the concert after the first or second
song
they should have stopped the show
because the crowd was screaming for help
travis saw an ambulance in the crowd he
saw what was going on the eight concert
goers killed include franco patino a 21
year old college student originally from
illinois his family released a statement
saying franco was a beloved friend
cousin nephew brother and son he was
loved by so many because of the loyal
loving selfless protective funny and
caring person he was patino's best
friend jake jurenick was also killed 23
year old rudy pena was also killed that
night his family set up a gofundme
account for funeral expenses in a
lawsuit filed over the weekend survivor
manuel souza claims plaintiff's injuries
were the inevitable and predictable
result of defendants conscious disregard
of the extreme risks of harm to concert
goers that had been escalating since
hours earlier the suit includes photos
of what sousa claims our concert goers
breaching a security gate and stampeding
into the stadium trampling people it
also includes a tweet from travis scott
from 9 36 that night stating gnaw and we
still sneaking the wild ones in
scott hasn't responded to the lawsuit
but tweeted saturday he's absolutely
devastated by what took place houston pd
has my total support as they continue to
look into the tragic loss of life i am
committed to working together with the
houston community
to heal and support the families in need
live nation has released a couple of
statements on twitter saying that the
company is heartbroken and has met
with law enforcement and actually
provided some security video from the
venue in the event drake meanwhile has
not responded to a request for comment
and houston's police chief is actually
confirming an earlier report that he met
with travis scott that night before the
concert started and expressed his
concerns about safety throughout the
weekend and during the concert
imran
yeah real tragedy and we are joined now
by co-host terry austin and former
federal prosecutor gene rossi gene i
want to start with you
we've heard at least two civil lawsuits
have already been filed do you think
there's going to be some criminal
liability here
there could be because um the key for a
criminal prosecution to me
is what did they know before this
concert started regarding the risk that
there would occur a stampede would occur
and if you had a lot of incidences or
notices to the concert organizers and to
travis scott that there could be this
problem this avalanche that caused eight
people to die absolutely you could bring
criminal charges
and terry what about the civil lawsuits
that have already been filed what do the
plaintiffs need to show in those cases
well those cases are based on negligence
they have personal injury attorneys who
are handling the case and they have to
show that there was a breach of a duty
and quite frankly
everyone has been sued travis scott the
performer the promoter live nation and
even the organizers and the organizers
said they're going to give a full refund
but that's hardly going to do anything
as far as the families are concerned
there's so many unanswered questions
imran for instance who did know what and
when did they know it so i think frankly
whether or not there was enough security
whether or not there was an action plan
for people in case of an emergency all
those have to be answered
yeah and anjanette back to you this is
not the first time something like this
has happened at a concert has it
imran you know it's really unfortunate
there's a lot that you could discuss
when answering that question first of
all travis scott back in arkansas in
2017 was actually charged with inciting
a riot because he was encouraging people
to rush the stage he pleaded guilty to
disorderly conduct in that case and paid
a fine and a man is actually suing
travis scott after he said he was left
paralyzed from injuries after attending
one of scott's concerts in manhattan
that same year in 2017
and of course we have to go back to 1979
where festival seating was kind of
largely banned in the concert industry
after people were crushed at a who
concert this wasn't a festival seating
type environment but it was standing
room only
leading to people being crushed during
that concert yeah a real tragedy and
we're all going to be watching the legal
ramifications that happen afterwards and
coming up here on law and crime daily
the state of wisconsin versus kyle
rittenhouse hear the firsthand account
of the only surviving man who rin house
shot
plus the latest in the so-called
doomsday duo case how last month's
development in lori valo dabel's case
could have an effect on her husband's
court proceedings all that and more
coming up next
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
special court hearing may soon be
arranged for half of the so-called
doomsday duo this as chad dave bell's
attorneys call for more information
about allegations that wife laurie
valodebel was forced to speak with a
religious attorney as law and crime
daily first reported last month
allegations emerged that laurie
valodebel gave privileged information to
a church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints attorney valodebel's attorneys
argue a state-issued clinician persuaded
her to contact the lds church telling
her it was part of her quote homework
for treatment
valodebel's attorney says the lds
attorney unethically contacted a state
prosecutor with inside information on
friday chad dabel's attorneys requested
an evidentiary hearing on the issue
arguing it quote implicates chad day
bell and could affect his due process
and fair trial rights day bell's
attorneys asked that the court interview
this staff member and the lds attorneys
involved
laurie balodebel and chad dabell are
co-defendants in the case they are
charged with the murder of her two
children tyler ryan and jj valo the
bodies of both children were found on
chad davell's property in june of 2020.
let's break this down terry chad daybell
is arguing that he has the right to see
the information surrounding lori's
communication with the church of
latter-day saints should the court grant
this request
actually imran i think the court should
grant that request chad is a
co-defendant in this case he has a right
to see all of the evidence he has to
properly prepare for his case and in
fact if the prosecution is aware of any
exculpatory evidence meaning obviously
evidence that can show that the
defendant is not guilty and if that is
the case then the prosecution has to
show that i think the whole situation is
a bit odd because why would laurie need
to be talking to the attorneys for the
latter day saints and what if she told
them that it was all her idea so i think
chad's motion is the right motion here
and i do think he should be able to see
all of the evidence in this case
including any conversation between lori
and the latter-day saints attorney yeah
i agree and jeanne laurie valo dabel was
deemed incompetent to stand trial back
in june more than five months have
passed what happens if she is never
deemed competent to stand trial
she won't go to trial you cannot try a
person who is deemed incompetent that's
a that's a given but i suspect that at
some point in the next couple months uh
they will conclude that she is competent
to testify and bear in mind the burden
of proof is on a defendant to show
incompetence it's not on the prosecution
because a person is presumed competent
to stand trial and a defense has to show
by preponderance that she's incompetent
but i think a judge is going to find her
suitable to try the case
great analysis and we're definitely
gonna be uh watching all the
developments in both these cases but
when we come back here on law and crime
daily the only surviving victim of the
kyle rittenhouse shootings takes the
stand we take you inside the wisconsin
courtroom to hear from gage grosskroyds
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
only surviving victim of the 2020
kenosha shootings takes the stand as a
witness in the state of wisconsin versus
kyle rittenhouse
eighteen-year-old rittenhouse faces
multiple charges including first degree
murder reckless murder and attempted
murder following the august 2020
shootings in kenosha wisconsin
prosecutors say rittenhouse shot and
killed joseph rosenbaum and anthony
huber and injured gay's gauge
prosperoids rittenhouse team argues that
the defendant was acting in self-defense
to begin the second week of trial the
state's prosecution called gross kreutz
to the stand to explain what led up to
the shooting
in that moment
i felt that i had to
do something to try and prevent myself
from being killed or being shot or
killed if it meant
triangle
anthony had just tried
wrestling the gun
detaining the defendants
i i
i don't know because i
never had an opportunity um i do know
though
i was never trying to kill the defendant
i was never never something that i was
trying to do in that moment
i was trying to preserve my own life
but doing so
while also taking the life of another is
not
something that i'm capable or
comfortable in doing that goes against
almost a lifelong
ethical code that i've lived by
now on cross-examination the defense
brought up the lawsuit gross kreutz has
filed against the city county and law
enforcement departments in kenosha
defense attorneys also pointed out the
night of the shooting gross crois was
carrying a weapon himself but that his
concealed carry permit had expired
you again failed to mention that you
possessed a firearm is that right
that is correct so you
in these documents that you are filing
with courts you are leaving out the fact
that you had possessed a firearm
when this when you were shot right
that is correct okay
and this is so
to be fair
uh this is
your testimony today
and how this case turns out has a has an
impact on your ability to try to collect
your 10 million right
that's correct
so if he's convicted if mr rittenhouse
is convicted your chance of getting 10
million bucks
is better right
i'm not entirely sure how that plays out
okay so let's bring in terry and gene to
break this down gene i'm going to start
with you the defense is trying to make
it sound like gage crows royce was the
aggressor will that be enough to get an
acquittal on attempted murder
absolutely their main defense is
self-defense
and if this witness was armed and he had
an expired carry permit uh
it goes to his intent
he says he's entered the fray to fracas
to try to protect people but he was
armed and we don't know if kyle
rittenhouse saw a a what was an object
that could be a firearm and here's the
other thing that last air of
cross-examination regarding his motive
i didn't like that answer by the witness
that he quote doesn't know how it's
going to play out everybody knows this
if you get a conviction in a criminal
case it helps the civil case because the
burdens are different so his answer was
a little bit too cute by half
yeah great analysis now terry mr
grosskroyce is a trained medic but he
was also carrying a handgun with an
expired license is that going to hurt
his testimony
well actually i agree with gene but i'm
going to argue the other side i thought
gross kroitz was very credible i think
despite the fact that he had an expired
gun carry license he is extremely you
know confident in front of the jury he's
a trained emt he knew what he was doing
unlike rittenhouse who wasn't really a
trained emt and who didn't know how to
use his gun without injuring and killing
people i do think the jury is going to
look at him and think listen he put his
hands up he didn't shoot at the
individual and he is credible so that's
it
and we are going to be following this
trial here at law and crime and thank
you for joining us on the law on crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you